Nvidia laid down some hard truths on the
industry Moore's Law is dead they said
gpus just can't get faster and cheaper
the way they used to they said and then
AMD was like
that's stupid here's faster gpus for
cheaper than the last generation God I'm
introducing the Radeon RX 7900
XT and XTX I want to make this very
clear these are not exactly value gpus
they're still coming in at 900 and a
thousand US dollars for the XT and the
XTX respectively but they are
significantly less expensive FPS per
dollar if AMD is to be believed then
Team Green and they are a hundred
dollars less expensive each than the
last generation top and almost top cards
from the 6000 Series so let's go ahead
and take a closer look at these bad boys
it gets even better as we go not only
are these cards delivering up to in the
range of 70 better performance than last
time around but look at this
they come in down right
you can get them out of the damn box
they come in downright reasonable form
factors wait is this no this is only the
XT this is only the XT maybe the XTX is
an absolute chungus monster but this is
this is totally fine here hold on a
second hold on a second I'm gonna tell
you more about it in a minute but first
let's pull out an RTX 4080 for
comparison what the heck I think it's
fair to say that the 7900 XT has more in
common physically with an RTX 2060 card
than the 4080. look at that is that wild
or what how did they do that
well for one thing it's rumored that the
RTX 4080 and 4090 were supposed to be
even power hungrier than they ended up
being which might be why the coolers for
them are so overbuilt for their final
tdps the other reason is that as I just
alluded to amd's power consumption for
these cards is to be clear very high at
300 and 355 Watts for the XT and the XTX
respectively but that's still within the
range of what you can do in a dual slot
not quite dual slot almost dual slot but
only full height card design that's one
of the really big ones how much taller
cards have gotten over the last little
while especially if you want to build a
small form factor machine or something
like that you've really run out of high
performance options another thing aside
from performance that we can talk about
here is the display outputs we've got
HDMI DisplayPort other more different
display port and USB type-c on the AMD
the reference cards but the coolest
thing about this is that these
DisplayPort ports are the new uhbr 10
DisplayPort 2.1 standard in practice
that may not end up meaning that much
because while AMD does advertise these
cards as capable of high refresh rate 4K
and even 8K gaming even amd's most
optimistic advertised numbers here are
nowhere near what uhbr10 can do we're
talking 4K at 480 Hertz and 8K at 165
Hertz uh I mean it's worth a try but I
don't think that's going to happen while
we're going over the physical attributes
of the cards power look at that no
controversial 12 pin power connector
dual 8-pin pcie power connector so you
won't need an adapter or to change out
the cables on your modular power supply
AMD like Nvidia has opted for a PCI
Express Gen 4 by 16 connector so if you
were hoping to take advantage of your
pcie Gen 5 motherboard in some way it
will be through storage not through your
GPU oh and I admit that having not
actually paid that close attention to
the presentations because
um other people were working on the
coverage I do not know if the XTX is
physically different or not
is it this is a little taller it's a
little taller it's a taller boy if you
wanted to know what 55 Watts looks like
like that
that much more this unboxing is brought
to you guys by Bessie Footwear that's
right when you get your vessi Footwear
it'll be a lot newer and cleaner than
this uh these are these are old but
that's good that's good that means they
last the Christmas season is upon us
which means that it's a great time to
stay warm and dry vessi boasts that
their sneakers are lightweight easy to
pack and feature waterproof materials
that offer you reassurance when the
weather can't their dime attacks layer
will keep you warm in the winter and
cool in the summer they're comfy
breathable and did I mention already
that they're lightweight making vessies
the perfect gift for yourself or for
someone else check out their holidaysale
at vessey.com Short Circuit or use code
short circuit at checkout if you just
missed it for 15 off plus free shipping
to select countries aside from their
performance claims though one of amd's
biggest marketing points for the 7000
series is the improved to Performance
per watt that they've made with our dna3
and they've done this in a number of
kind of cool ways so first of all
they're using a combination of tsmc's
five nanometer and six nanometer
processes to build the first ever
triplet GPU there are some functions
that they can't move off of the main die
like compute Hardware Graphics hardware
and display in media engines that main
dies built on tsmc's five nanometer
process so they can pack as much as
possible in and they really did I mean
this thing's got literally twice as many
stream processors as amd's previous
Flagship card but they were able to move
their gddr6 controllers and other i o
functions onto these either 5 for the XT
or six mcds or memory cache dies and the
reasons for this are twofold one is to
save cost and two is to well mostly save
cost because apparently these functions
don't really shrink that well so it just
wasn't worth it from a from a cost
perspective so that's the main reason I
guess either way the bandwidth between
the gcd so that's the main one and the
mcds is a whopping what is this 5.3
terabytes a second so that's 900 gigs a
second per MCD absolutely flipping wild
one of the other big innovations that
AMD has introduced to improve
performance per watt is decoupled clock
speeds so they are apparently running
the shaders and the front end on these
gpus at different speeds so the shaders
are advertised at a game clock of 2.3
gigahertz while the front end is
expected to hit in the neighborhood of
2.5 is that for both cards or are those
clocks different between the two ah yes
that's for the XTX so the XT is in the 2
to 2.4 gigahertz range the reason for
doing this is apparently that by backing
off even just part of the card a little
bit off of that voltage per frequency
curve you can save a ton of power
without giving up too much in terms of
performance AMD has also added dedicated
AI accelerators to these cards so we're
looking at two AI accelerators per
compute unit but what exactly they're
going to be using these for is not clear
at this time to date AMD does not have
an AI accelerated dlss competitor but I
would imagine that something like that
wouldn't be too far behind if they're
putting the hardware out for them AMD
does have a pretty okay reputation for
um well there's sort of two ways to look
at this not having fully developed
drivers at launch or or glass half full
way of looking at it really squeezing
extra out of their cards over their
lifespan so it's quite possible that we
will see big improvements to these cards
through AI accelerated rendering tricks
over the next few years one thing
they're using AI for right out of the
gate is apparently to help their
encoding and decoding performance this
is something that's been been a bit of a
thorn in the side of AMD lovers for the
last well I mean yeah many years
actually that nvidia's end banking
coding engine is just a lot better for
things like game streaming or even just
screen capping so that you can share a
quick tutorial with your friends I'm
really hoping that amd's h.264 and h.265
are going to be much better performance
than before and more than that I'm
hoping that I don't have to worry about
h.264 and h.265 for much longer because
av1 will just take over and be the
industry standard and amd's av1 encoder
will be great and that's that's what I'm
really rooting for here the XT has 20
Gigabytes of gddr6 while the XTX has 24
gigabytes of gddr6 and we're expecting a
performance Delta between the two of
them of somewhere in the neighborhood of
uh wait is anybody even talking about
that yet damn it AMD the XT is going to
be slower though I mean look at it it's
smaller if the volume is anything to go
by
and probably be about say 20 percent
slower not how that works by the way I
think the last big thing you guys need
to know is that these cards are coming
December 13th and we are expecting to
have a full performance review with
power consumption clock speeds FPS all
that good stuff up at that time so that
you guys will know has AMD dethroned
Nvidia or not well we all know the
answer to that even AMD is not comparing
these cards to the 4090 but come on
that's a sixteen hundred dollar card who
cares if you could have like 4080
performance for 900 or a thousand
dollars instead of twelve hundred
dollars
I think you'd be uh maybe not happy but
you'll take it just like you'll take the
end of this video subscribe to Short
Circuit